RUSSIAN SPY ON BRITISH SOIL.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON HAS A
REACTION TO IT FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> WE WILL NOT TOLERATE SUCH A
BRAZEN ATTEMPT TO MURDER
INNOCENT CIVILIANS ON OUR SOIL.
>> BRITISH PRIME MINISTER
THERESA MAY SAYS IT'S HIGHLY
LIKELY RUSSIA IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
POISONING A FORMER SPY WITH
MILITARY GRADE NERVE AGENT IN
SOUTHWESTERN ENGLAND.
HER GOVERNMENT HAS SUMMONED
RUSSIA'S AMBASSADOR TO THE
UNITED KINGDOM TO EXPLAIN BY
TOMORROW WHETHER HIS GOVERNMENT
EITHER EXECUTED THE ATTACK OR
LOST CONTROL OF ITS NERVE AGENT.
>> SHOULD THERE BE NO CREDIBLE
RESPONSE, WE WILL CONCLUDE THIS
ACTION AMOUNTS TO AN UNLAWFUL
USE OF FORCE BY THE RUSSIAN
STATE AGAINST THE
UNITED KINGDOM.
>> MAY AS IT CANNOT BE BUSINESS
AS USUAL WITH RUSSIA AND BRITAIN
WOULD CONSIDER MUCH MORE
EXTENSIVE MEASURES THAN
DIPLOMATIC EXPULSIONS.
LAST WEEK, SERGEI SKIPRAL AND
HIS DAUGHTER WERE FOUND
POISONED.
THEY ARE IN THE HOSPITAL IN
CRITICAL STABLE CONDITION.